I was on trial by the new Audi rs5 now
has just six cylinders instead of eight
explains our car man line so what else
is do well the previous naturally
aspirated engine has been ditched in
favor of a twin turbocharged unit seem
familiar yes from Audi VW sister brand
Porsche for better performance and
better economy but enough talking let's
get out on the road the elegant two-door
rs5 is the first Audi performance model
to feature the new design vocabulary the
big single frame radiator grille is
still there although it's wider and
flatter than in the entry-level model at
the back the rs5 has the typical oval
exhaust outlets weighing in at 1655
kilograms the new coupe a is around 60
kilos heavier than its predecessor it
has pretensions of being a sporty Grand
Turismo and a car you can comfortably
cover long distances in two
that's all I notice impressed with a
suspension and not just in the super
hard sports setting but in the comfort
mode too you certainly can use the rs5
as a Gran Turismo with plenty of space
for passengers in cargo the new v6
engine delivers spontaneous response and
masses of torque it develops 600 Newton
meters of output at 1,900 - 5,000 revs
per minute the RS 5 turbo now has the
propulsive power of an express train the
coupe a makes the dash to 100 km/h and
3.9 seconds its predecessor needed half
a second longer turbochargers are
located between the v-shaped cylinder
banks it can get pretty hot down there
which is why the setup is called a hot
inner V but the short exhaust gas paths
translate into a superior response when
you step on the gas 450 horsepower or
331 kilowatts are a lot of power just as
in the preceding version but the torque
is grown by 170 Newton meters in
comparison the engine and the Opel Adam
has a total torque of 170 Newton meters
dedication is often in the detail and
that also applies to the Neal Audi the
performance coupe a is a real looker and
you can have plenty of fun pushing up
the pace
you
typically for Audi the interior is
uncluttered with no profusion of knobs
scattered around the place everything
has its proper place here
the dashboard is optionally available
with carbon-fiber finishing combined
with lots of leather and Alcantara
the leather sports seats are optionally
available with honeycomb stitching the
rs5 has been transformed from beefy
tough guy to long distance GT with
prices in Germany starting at just under
eighty one thousand euros it costs about
three thousand more than its predecessor
[Music]
the official fuel economy is 8.7 liters
for 100 kilometers but madam could call
up maximum output its biggest rivals are
the BMW m4 the Mercedes AMG c63 the AMG
is the only one with eight cylinders